what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to millionaire youtuber
said he could have been a predator oh
gosh um before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily
videos
um i moved to england in two days so
this is probably gonna be um
the last reaction videos i'm gonna be
doing like before i go so yeah hit that
subscribe button because you'll get to
like stay updated with me on my journey
there
but okay all i had to do was just show
up
and they would service me i remember one
sunday i [ __ ] all three of them i
[ __ ] the mom i [ __ ] the daughters
and the youngest one was really really
[ __ ] tight oh gosh
and their mom was like yeah we gotta
open up that [ __ ] ew
yeah i mean
you're [ __ ] her and their mom's like
that that's it take that dick take that
dick oh my god in the beginning i have
never heard of anything
like more awkward like what on earth
both of the girls
were
oh my gosh that is so sad
in the beginning it used to hurt her
and she was like
it hurts mom it hurts
that's such a big dick it hurts
and then after
a few times and i loosen up that [ __ ]
then she start getting into it
then she turned to this day this girl is
a bona fide black [ __ ] [ __ ] freak
whoever she's [ __ ] right now is very
happy oh
because you
probably traumatized her
so
once again
i don't believe our kelly's a predator
i think he has an appetite oh no that
got him in trouble
here's the thing and i forget the
billionaire who was running the sexual
trafficking
i forget his name i can see him he was a
blond
white guy
epstein
he had that same appetite
now i
[ __ ] this that young girl 17 year old
the mom and her daughters and that was
you know
and there was a few more but i did not
look or hunt or subscribe to those young
girls
i perfectly my perfect age ring which
was like 24 to about 34. that was where
i operated quite a bit
but i'm here to go i'm here to tell you
that
especially with the billionaire
these girls would go out and recruit
girls and they were adults they were 100
aware of what they're doing
they were like i am going to get this
girl so she can have sex with this old
billionaire
she knew
there was no gun in her head well i mean
yeah the recruiters but like the young
girl who who's like
being recruited to do that
like you have to know you're taking
advantage of young girls like i i know
some some of them like probably knew
what they were doing
a lot of them did but
you have to understand your brain isn't
fully developed when you're a kid
like we all know there's dumb stuff
we've done we're teenagers and
especially if like you're going for
girls that like
don't have that solid of a family
structure and they were stuffing her
palms with cash
how is she a victim
how is he a predator
and this is one of the things that um
like i could be considered the predator
because i've had a lot of sex with a lot
of women
i could be considered a womanizer
because i like slinging the dick
okay so guys you know r kelly
he went too far
he brought other people in he had an
organization
they probably got him for trafficking
and all this other stuff i never went
nowhere near that level i never had
anyone go out and find girls for me
never did that i did all my own work
and this is one of the reasons i never
got in trouble
oh gosh i remember
the mother and the two daughters
in one saturday i go over there
and the mother and the oldest one
are out
and just the young one
right so i'm talking to her and
everything and next thing you know i
take her titties out start sucking on
their titties
and i [ __ ] her
and this is the first time i [ __ ] her
and she came
and it blew her mind
it blew her mind
so
i understand r kelly on a deeper level
once again
did he commit these crimes
i would say yes he had sex with young
women
i would say these young women were
complicit
they were willing because he was r kelly
i'm here to tell you guys it is not that
hard for an older man to get a very
young girl
it's not that hard at all there are many
girls out there who are looking for
older men
looking
searching
hunting for older men
and they're 14
15
16
and they have no problem taking the dick
from a 25 35 or even a 45 year old man
none whatsoever
and
part of this is
if r kelly wasn't r kelly
i don't think none of this will win down
i feel that r kelly pissed off the wrong
person
i don't know what he did but he pissed
off the wrong person and that launched
this investigation because i saw this
tape of r kelly pissing on this girl
ugh
[Applause]
i saw this tape it was him
it was him
and he's had this appetite
since elia
and i personally don't think there's
anything wrong with older guys liking
younger girls because okay within reason
not underage oh my gosh
i think he was 21 and she was 16.
to me that's not a really big difference
but r kelly had that our appetite
he had that appetite
and that appetite
can ruin you
i have
somewhat of an appetite but i have
limits there's just certain things i'm
not going to do
there's just certain boundaries i'm not
going to cross
and
essentially i conducted my [ __ ]
in the safe zone
i did stuff i knew i could get away with
i did not go out like there was this one
girl
and she was super cute and then
i did uh my research on her and saw her
pictures of her with her mom and dad
which means her parents were very much
involved in her life
oh and that there would have been the
danger zone oh no
this is how it happens
she comes over we [ __ ] she goes home her
mom and dad press her he's like i [ __ ]
this old man
and next thing you know mom and dad call
the police oh no
knocking at your door
that's how that goes down so i never put
myself in the crosshairs of the danger
zone so so you're trying to find a girl
that doesn't have
parents involved oh gosh and it really
wasn't in comparison to the number of
women it wasn't a lot
but i can tell you
young [ __ ]
can be [ __ ] amazing
when you stick your dick in some [ __ ]
they never had a dick in it before whoa
it's so tight it's so warm it's so snug
and i feel that the r kelly's and once
again this white billionaire put his
name in the comments because i know
y'all gonna google him
and um
i feel that as a man you have to know
what you can get away with and what you
can do and what you can't and once again
i feel that r kelly pissed someone off
because if r kelly was just
robert
the truck driver
it never even if he did all of these
things he would have never went to jail
ah
i don't know about that r kelly
there was something he did ah
i don't know about that
there's someone in power he pissed off
and that's why because the thing is they
went after him for years and years and
years they were after him like a dog on
a bone
they were after him
and there was a reason they were after
him because
what r kelly did
happens
every
damn
day
right now
there's some old dude [ __ ] the
teenager right now
right now
there is some old dude
sliding the sausage up in some young
[ __ ]
right now
this is how common is
it is a common thing in america
and don't even talk about the rest of
the world
rest of the world hands up just let that
go
but
if i had allowed my appetite to get out
of hand
i could have been in
trouble and i consciously knew what i
was doing and i consciously i got like
this sixth sense right that lets me know
when something's not cool is about to
happen uh when it's illegal oh my god
there was just certain chicks who were
answering they were tasty they were
beautiful they would send me photos of
their titties and their [ __ ] and all
this other stuff and i was just like
nope not that one
that's the danger zone that is the
danger zone that is the danger zone that
is the danger zone and i never mess with
those chicks
if a girl was young
and she was halfway close to her parents
you could be looking at jail time
because
what they're going to do
i can't believe this man
one thinks like this
says this right but you know you you
know there's [ __ ] up people in the
world so whatever
but that now not only that most people
that are messed up in the head don't
have the audacity
to put on a camera to like turn on the
camera record themselves and upload that
[ __ ] to the internet like this is crazy
they're gonna they're gonna fold they're
going to take the deck they're going to
do all this stuff and when mom and dad
start putting the heat on them they're
going to fold like a cheap
sheet
and they're like this is what we did and
the next thing you know mom and dad are
calling 9-1-1
because some man some old man
defiled their young daughter
some old man put his mature penis in a
[ __ ]
i feel so uncomfortable
we can't have that so you cannot be
messing with girls who have intensive
parent parental contact you can't be
messing with them and i feel now once
again there are so many girls out here
you know like these pimps
these girls are looking for a daddy and
these pimps serve as a daddy figure
this is like i'm telling you
you know sometimes they'll get them
hooked on drugs sometimes they don't
sometimes the pimp just has to snap his
fingers and this girl will do whatever
he wants her to do because she's looking
for daddy
she's looking for daddy
oh gosh so it really
depends upon who you are and how you
look at this
but i personally don't think r kelly's a
predator
i feel that he has a voracious appetite
he has a certain type it is illegal is
underage
and he allowed that appetite to
literally ruin his life because
i guarantee you r kelly knows who's
after him
and once he should once he figured out
that someone was after him he should
have
hit the chill pill but he didn't he kept
going he kept going
and they kept after him they kept going
now he's going to jail oh yeah
that that was the issue i could have
been a predator
same energy
same appetite yeah
i'm a nobody
i'm a nobody
that's why i was able to do this stuff
and get away with it because i'm a
nobody but if i was an r kelly or this
this billionaire dude or if i was
someone like that
oh gosh okay this is like the grossest
thing i've watched in a while
oh god like this is gonna make me feel
sick the rest of the day
there are always gonna be people out
there that like will take advantage of
young girls um i do think you know
a lot of times girls without like proper
guidance put themselves in those
situations but like you have a level of
responsibility when you're the adult and
that's a child
so that this is all just crazy to me let
me know in the comments what you guys
think but
yeah this was this was gross um don't
forget to subscribe i'll talk to you
guys next